and some of Avengers endgames crew to
the list of people who weren't thrilled
with Thor's husky new look in a recent
interview with Empire magazine the flick
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely revealed that the
Thunder gods new appearance didn't sit
well with some of those who were on the
production set in case you're one of the
six people who hasn't seen the film yet
be advised that spoilers for Avengers
endgame follow you recall that after
endgames five-year time jump Professor
Hulk and Rockets set out for new Asgard
to track down Thor who had dealt with
his failure to prevent the decimation in
a rather unhealthy manner specifically
he had spent the previous half decade
drinking enough beer to drown an
elephant playing fortnight's and growing
the type of guts you rarely see on
superheroes many fans felt that Thor's
obvious depression in new courtly
physique were being played for laughs
although later scenes treated his
fragile mental state with sensitivity
allowing it to play into his larger
character arc and making the near
immortal god that much more relatable
for the audience
according to Markus and McFeely a few
unnamed crew members took issue Marcus
told Empire there was a sad moment where
it was like we've got this gross
disgusting body for Thor now and then
they unveiled it and it's just kind of
like everybody else's body here it's a
nice way of putting it
McFeely added there were many people on
set who were angry at us about doing
that to Thor McFeely however implied
that the onset anger wasn't necessarily
because they felt that Thor's condition
was being handled with a lack of tact
but because the screenwriters had seen
fit to send the character on his
downward spiral at all
Markus agreed saying that it was simply
a brutal shock to see just how to
spawned it the mighty Odin sin had
become I don't drink tea what do you
drink not tea
[Music]
nobody not even the god of thunder could
put away that much beer without packing
on a few pounds in the process and it's
not like Thor went on any kind of crash
diet before jumping back into the mix to
take part in the Avengers most important
mission yet
he would still test the structural
integrity of the Megan New York if you
catch our drift we just got a load
Toni's old Hulkbuster armor prototype
for caps new shield and the Megan the
mech then Thor's magic belt Markus
defended the decision to keep Thor beefy
throughout endgame saying I like that
heroes come in all shapes and sizes
Thor comes from a tradition of guys like
Volstagg of a big ass-kicking fat guy
there's no reason that he has to slim
down we hope that the character of Thor
continues to be explored in interesting
in unexpected ways as he may be the only
original Avenger who will continue to be
a presence in the films of base for end
games conclusion saw him heading off
into the cosmos to find new adventures
with the guardians of the galaxy and
Tessa Thompson who portrays new Asgard's
new ruler Valkyrie recently let slip to
the Los Angeles Times that he might also
very well be the first MCU character to
get a fourth solo flick of course it
wouldn't be too surprising if the god of
thunder were to shed all those extra
pounds before his next appearance but
one could simply chalk that up to there
being no decent beer in space check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
and gamer coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]